Am
I good? There we go. Hi guys.
Hi. Welcome. Welcome to the table. Those
of you that are here on time, I wish I
had like a prize for you.
We can just awkwardly stare at everybody
as they walk in and be silent like we're
waiting for you. [laughter]
[gasps] Good evening. My name is Karen
Miner and uh it's Sunday at the table.
I'm so glad you're here. I have a few
announcements. Actually, I have quite a
few announcements.
So, I'm going to get right to it. Um
since our rental situation here at First
Saxi doesn't make it feasible for us to
have a Christmas Eve service, we are
going to have our Christmas service on
Sunday, December 21st here, 5:00 pm. Um
So, please come, invite anybody that
you'd like, anyone that might enjoy a
service and a church community like
ours. Uh, we'll have candle lighting,
we'll sing Christmas carols, it will be
a familyfriendly service. Uh, so again,
that will be on Sunday, December 21st,
5:00 pm here. Uh secondly, if you are
interested in baptism, uh Brett will be
having a baptism class uh next Sunday
and that will be before the service. So
if you're interested in baptism, um if
you just have questions about it, feel
free to grab Brett after service tonight
and talk to him about it.
Thirdly, one of our favorite
organizations, uh, nonprofits called
Centerpiece is having a stories and
tunes event on, uh, let's see, that will
be this coming Friday night from 7 to
900 p.m. And, uh, Centerpiece is a local
beloved LGBTQ Christian organization.
They're amazing. And so if you would
like to listen to stories, listen to
beautiful music, uh we would encourage
you to attend that. Uh that will be at
Union Coffee in Dallas, which is another
great great venue. Uh let's see what
else. Oh,
welcome to December. Here we are. It's
the first Sunday and around here at the
table on first Sundays, we have a meal
together. So tonight, immediately
following the service, we'll be headed
to Hat Creek Burger Company in Saxi off
of 78 uh for a meal. So please, please
head over there after the service. It's
a great time to get to know other people
in our community, hang out, have a
burger or a salad or whatever you like.
Um so we'll be doing that tonight after
the service.
All right. Lastly, we have an
accessibility bucket. It's over there.
Black bucket on the bookcase. If you
need a fidget, headphones, something
just to keep your hands and your mind
occupied while you're here, feel free to
check that out. Um, just return anything
that you borrow.
And then just a reminder, the candles to
my left and right are a sign of the
presence of Christ among us, fully human
and fully divine.
So, I don't know about you, but this
time of year, while it's fun and
festive, can also be really overwhelming
and harried and
frantic and frenetic. And it can also
include grief. It can include struggle,
can include relational
tension.
So, let this be your refuge.
Let this be your respit.
Let this be a place where you can be
fully yourself.
So let's just take a breath together.
Inhale.
Nice deep breath in.
Let it out.
Close your eyes if you like.
Just feel yourself landing here now.
Set everything else aside.
Be present.
Be here now.
Now we exit the kingdom of noise, hurry,
and productivity.
Now we enter the kingdom of silence,
stillness, and simplicity.
A sacred space, a place for prayer,
worship, and adoration.
A place to behold Christ.
Revelation of God. Heartbeat of
creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to
find you to mend your heart.
May we all come home.
Thanks Karen. You guys want to stand
with us? We're going to start tonight
with a [music] Christmas carol. We
officially are in December.
Go [music] tell it on the mountain
over [singing] the hills and everywhere.
[music]
Go tell it on the mountain [singing]
that Jesus [music] Christ is born.
>> [music]
>> While shephers kept [music and singing]
their watching over silent flocks by
night, [music] behold [singing]
throughout the heavens they're shown a
holy life. [music] Oh, [singing]
go tell it on the mountain,
over the hills and [music and singing]
everywhere.
Go tell it on the mountain [singing]
that Jesus Christ is [music] born.
He is born. [music and singing]
[music]
The shepherds [singing] feared and
trembled with [music] low on the earth.
Ring out [singing] the angels chorus
that held the savior's [music] birth. Oh
[singing] go tell it on the mountain
[music]
over the hills and [singing] everywhere.
Oh, [music] tell it on the mountain that
Jesus [singing]
Christ is born.
[music]
[music] Yeah, he's
down in a lonely [singing]
manger.
The humble Christ [music] was born and
God sent us salvation
that mercy Christmas [singing] morning.
[music] Go tell it on the mountain
over the hills and [music and singing]
everywhere.
Go tell it on the mountain [singing]
that Jesus Christ is born. [music]
Let's go [singing]
tell it on the mountain. Over the hills
[music and singing] and everywhere.
Go tell it on the mountain that Jesus
Christ is born. [music]
That Jesus Christ [singing] is born.
That Jesus [music]
Christ [singing] is born.
All right, you kids are dismissed to go
to your classrooms. Thank you, Rhysa,
and all of our teachers, Maggie.
[laughter]
Yay.
We will see you guys after the service
and um we're going to transition into
the prayers of the people. So, um, if
this is your first time here, the words
will be up on the screen and you can
read aloud the parts that are in red
together. And then we'll pause for a
moment in the middle of the prayer to
just speak out something that's on your
heart tonight. Whether it's a person or
a situation that you're carrying, we
want to make space for that, to
acknowledge it because God is here with
us. He knows what we're walking through
and uh he is present in our struggles
and we want to be present to one another
as well.
Jesus, for this city of Saxi, Texas, and
for every city and community and all who
live in them, we pray to you for the
good earth that you have given us, and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it.
We pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and the orphan, [music]
for the injured and suffering. We pray
to you for the [music] poor and the
oppressed, the unemployed and destitute,
for prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them. We pray to
you for the vulnerable, the marginalized
and those unjustly [music] targeted for
their gender, sexuality, race, or other
perceived [music] difference. We pray to
you for those experiencing loss,
loneliness, and disconnection. And for
those struggling with mental and
emotional health, we pray to you, Lord.
We know that you love us and that you
hear us. So we lift these names and
situations up to you.
For the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud. And for those that we
have kept in our hearts, we [music] pray
to you that they may have life and
light, healing and hope, peace and a
deep sense of your presence. Amen.
>> [music]
>> We [music] used to feel all kinds of
grief.
>> Tasted the bit of tea. [music]
>> I love the bitter cup of something
sweet. Our faith more preious [music]
than gold.
>> We [singing and music] have been tested
by so many fires.
>> Burning [music] the heat of what our
hope requires.
>> Why singing in a [music] foolish?
I more precious than gold. Our
more precious gold. [music]
Though we don't see you, we love
[music and singing] you.
>> When we don't feel you, we still see.
>> We've [music and singing] got reasons to
trust you,
Jesus, [music and singing] in
everything.
[music]
Everything, Lord.
Give it all [music] to you, Lord.
[music]
>> There [music] is a secret we can only
know.
>> Walking [music] through places we don't
want [singing] to go.
In [music] the dark we wear the songs of
hope. Our faith more preious
[music and singing] than gold.
>> Our faith more precious [music]
than [singing] gold.
[music]
>> Though we see you, we love [singing]
you.
When we [music] don't feel you, we still
sing.
We've got [music and singing] the reason
to trust you.
Jesus in everything.
[music]
Jesus in [singing] everything.
[music] Tears on the altar
for all we lost.
Following you no matter what it cost.
[singing]
Maybe you whisper, maybe you roar. This
[singing] is the sound [music] of those
who love you, Lord. This is the sound of
those who [music] love you, Lord.
Tears on [singing] the altar from all
[music] we lost.
Following you, no matter what it
[singing] cost.
Maybe a whisper, [music]
maybe [singing] a roar. This is the
sound of those who love you, Lord. This
[music and singing] is the sound of
those who love you, Lord.
Though we don't see you, we love you.
Where we don't feel you, we still see
you. [music] We've got a reason to trust
you,
Jesus, [singing] in [music] everything.
Let's sing that again.
Though we don't see you, we want you.
[music] When [singing] we don't feel
you, we still see.
We've got [music] a reason to trust you.
Jesus in everything.
[music] Jesus.
Jesus in everything. Jesus. [music]
Jesus in everything.
[music] Tears on the [singing] altar
from all we lost.
Following you no matter what it cost.
[music]
>> Maybe you whisper,
maybe you're
This is [music and singing] the sound of
those who love you, Lord.
This is the sound of [singing] those who
love you. [music]
This is the sound of those who love you.
>> Yeah.
>> This week I've been thinking a lot about
um the impact that Vicky Ferris had on
this community. Um, and for those of you
who may be new around here, Vicki is one
of our members who's been at the table
for a number of years and um, was just
such a committed, faithful um, believer,
somebody whose life was marked with
tragedy and loss all along the way. And
one Sunday, she actually stood up here
and gave her testimony. And her words
have been ringing in my head this week.
um how someone who went through so much
suffering
in my experience was so faithful and was
full of joy and so much support in
others and such [music] an advocate and
such a supporter. And as I was singing
through this song this week um that
[music] we just sang, some of the lines
just stood out to me. Um,
I was thinking about how it said
following you no matter what the cost.
There was a big cost through her life,
but she just continued to follow.
Singing in a foolish choir, our faith
more precious than gold.
Vicki had blue hair. She wanted to be up
here playing tambourine. That's what she
always said. Like, maybe you could just
let me get a shake or a tambourine. I
could just get up there and just play
with [music] y'all. She loved to worship
and I mean that woman would have been a
fool to the ends of the earth if it
meant getting to worship [music] and
sing her heart and be a part of a
community that she loved. And it's just
it's like the weight of um what a
[music] gift we have to be together.
what a gift this life is. What a gift
this community is has just sunk in at a
[music]
just a new level for me this week as
I've sung these songs, as I've thought
of her life and her legacy. And um
[music] I just want to read this passage
from Romans 5 before we sing this next
one. It says, "Therefore, since we've
been justified through faith, we have
peace with God through our [music] Lord.
Though we have gained access by faith
into this grace in which we now stand.
And we [music] boast in the hope of the
glory of God. Not only so, but we also
glory in our suffering [music] because
we know that suffering produces
perseverance. Perseverance character.
And character hope. And hope [music]
does not put us to shame because God's
love has been poured out into our hearts
through the Holy Spirit whom we have
been given.
And tonight, if we can hold on to that
hope that Vicki had, the hope that when
we [music] come together, there is
goodness and life here. No matter what
we've experienced outside [music] of
these walls, no matter who may be
against you, when we come together and
sing to a God who [music] loves us, who
can be against us?
When God is for us, [music] who can be
against us? So, let's hang on to those
words tonight.
>> [music]
[singing]
>> It doesn't matter if
[music]
I will stay with [singing] you, my
[music] God.
I will stay with you.
It [music and singing] doesn't matter if
the whole world turns
away. I will [music] stay with [singing]
you, my God.
I will stay with you. Let's sing [music]
that again. It doesn't [singing] matter
if the whole world turns
away. [music] I will stay with you, my
God.
I will stay [music] with you.
No, [singing] it doesn't matter [music]
if the whole world turns [singing] away.
I will stay with you, my God.
[music] I will stay with [singing] you.
Cuz [music] where can I go? Where can I
go? Where can I go? [singing]
Cuz only you have the [music] words of
life. Only you have the words [singing]
of life. [music] Where can I go? Where
can I go? Where can I go [singing]
when [music] only you have the words of
life?
>> [singing]
>> Only you have the life. [music]
And it doesn't matter if the whole
[music] world turns [singing]
away.
I will stay with you, my God.
I will [music] stay with [singing] you.
It doesn't matter [music] if the
[singing] whole world turns
away. [music]
I will stay with you, my God.
I will [music] stay with you.
Cuz where can I [music and singing] go?
Where can I go? Where can I go?
[singing]
Cuz [music] only you had the words of
mine. Only [singing]
you had the words of life. Where can I
[music] go? Where can I go? [singing]
Where can I go? [music]
With only you have the words of life.
[music and singing] Only you have the
words of life. Only you have [singing]
the words of life. Only [music] you have
the words.
>> [music]
>> No other [singing] well's going to
satisfy. [music]
No other word's going to be my life. No
other love that [music and singing] I'm
turning to. Jesus, you're my
breakthrough. [music] No other [singing]
world's going to satisfy.
No other word's going to be my [singing]
life. No other will that [music] I'm
turn into. Jesus, you're my
breakthrough.
No other [singing] world's going to
satisfy. [music]
No other word's going to be my life. No
other love [singing] that I'm turning
to. Jesus, you're my breakthrough.
[music]
Jesus, [music] you're my breakthrough.
Yeah. Jesus, you're my breakthrough.
[music]
It doesn't [singing] matter [music]
if the whole world turns
away. I will stay [singing] with you, my
God.
I will stay with you.
It doesn't matter if
[singing]
I will stay with you, my God,
I will stay with you.
[singing and music]
God, whatever this life throws at us,
whatever grief we've experienced,
whatever pain or tragedy or health
issue,
God, would we have the faithfulness to
turn to you because you are the only one
that satisfies.
You are the one that has life for us and
life to the fullest.
You are our hope,
our anchor.
God, would we continue to look to you,
to return to you,
to grab onto your words,
to root oursel in them?
God, would we remember that each [music]
struggle,
each shadow, God is producing [music] in
us something greater when we plant
ourselves in you
that you meet us there in the midst of
it. You are faithful.
You are good.
And we can trust you.
God. So, fill us up tonight.
Remind us of the times that you've met
us, that you've pulled us through,
the times that you've walked with us,
and you'll continue to do that over and
over again.
Let us hold on to that hope
in Jesus name. Amen.
All right, you [music] guys can be
seated. And would you turn to the person
on your right and left and say, "The
peace of Christ be with you.
>> Well, grace and peace.
My name is Brett and uh yeah, it's good
good to be with you all to welcome you
into this space and uh as always that
includes those joining us online. Love
you all lots. Don't forget your
communion elements for later uh in the
service. And yeah, it's just a beautiful
um time of year and great to to be
together uh you know, as the weather
turns colder and the days get a little
shorter and darkness descends. Um which
kind of leads into um this kind of
interesting and and beautiful time of
year we're in Advent. Uh I think it's
it's not, you know, kind of a
coincidence that um there's kind of this
uh well the shortening of the days and
such in this time. it kind of naturally
it kind of starts to turn you a little
more um contemplative in a way, you
know, a little more thoughtful, a little
more inward as you're just less, you
know, a little less social, less plans
every evening and the beautiful summer
weather and, you know, just there's
something about this time of year that
kind of turns you in that in that
direction. And so I think it's uh
appropriate for um Advent and this time
of year that we're in. Uh and I should
also also mention before I get too much
further, a big thank you to Charles
Kaiser. He's not here tonight, I don't
think, but um he spoke last week and
delivered such a beautiful word, such a
great great sermon and um just really
grateful for him and his his family and
how they're a part of of our community
and uh so he kind of kicked off Advent,
you know, for us. Um but the well kind
of many people think of Advent as kind
of like the celebration of um Christmas
when really it's it's more like uh
Advent is to what's called Christmas
tide or like the season of Christmas as
Lent is to Easter. So it's really kind
of a time of heart and mind preparation
to receive the birth of Christ. So um so
it's it's kind of less of yeah kind of
like hooray you know for Jesus. It's
it's not really that. Um, and you'll
you'll notice that as we get into these
readings each week, um, there it's a lot
of John the Baptist, uh, who kind of
famously in the Gospels is like the one
preparing the way for Jesus, you know,
and so that's why it makes perfect sense
like he's like the Advent guy because
that's really what Advent's about,
right? So it's not a lot of um Luke
chapter 2 assigned readings from the,
you know, the the Gospels. Um, not yet.
That comes, you know, in the the
Christmas season. So, um, with that in
mind, the title of my message tonight is
ruts, kings, and prophetic imagination.
And, uh, our reading is Matthew chapter
3:es 1-2,
which says this. In those days, John the
Baptist came preaching in the wilderness
of Judea,
saying, "Repent, for the kingdom of
heaven has come near.
This is he who was spoken of through the
prophet Isaiah.
A voice of one calling in the
wilderness. Prepare the way for the
Lord. Make straight paths for him.
John's clothes were made of camel<unk>s
hair. He had a leather belt around his
waist. His food was locusts and wild
honey. people went out to him from
Jerusalem and all Judea and the whole
region uh of the Jordan confessing their
sins. They were baptized by him in the
Jordan River. But when he saw many of
the Pharisees and Sadducees coming to
where he was baptizing, he said to them,
"You brood of vipers who warned you to
flee from the coming wrath, produce
fruit in keeping with repentance, and do
not think you can say to yourselves, we
have Abraham as our father. For I tell
you, out of these stones, God can raise
up children for Abraham. The axe is
already at the root of the trees. Every
tree that does not produce good fruit
will be cut down and thrown into the
fire. I baptize you with water for
repentance. But after me comes one who
is more powerful than I, whose sandals
I'm not worthy to carry. He will baptize
you with the Holy Spirit and fire. His
winnowing fork is in his hand, and he
will clear his threshing floor,
gathering his wheat into the barn and
burning up the chaff with unquenchable
fire.
So, you can see now why I said Advent
isn't uh it's not a celebration of the
baby in the manger. Like, where what is
this? A Christmas reading, you know? Uh
it's it's a different kind of vibe. It's
a it's a prophetic kind of whack, you
know? It's a it's a wakeup call, a
challenge. And so the way I want to
frame kind of my own reading of this
passage is uh with a quote from the Old
Testament theologian Walter Bugamman. He
wrote this I mean it might be his most
famous book um titled the prophetic
imagination. And uh we'll kind of unpack
this. It's a it's a little um academic
but um I think I love what he's kind of
getting at here. So he says this, "The
prophet engages in futuring fantasy.
The prophet does not ask if the vision
can be implemented for questions of
implementation are of no consequence
until the vision can be imagined.
The imagination must come before the
implementation.
Our culture is competent to implement
almost anything and to imagine almost
nothing. The same royal consciousness
that makes it possible to implement
anything and everything is the one that
shrinks imagination because imagination
is a danger.
Thus, every totalitarian regime is
frightened of the artist.
It is the vocation of the prophet to
keep alive. This is kind of the key
phrase here. The ministry of imagination
to keep on conjuring and proposing
futures alternative to the single one
the king wants to urge as the only
thinkable one.
So I know that's a lot. So but let me
kind of unpack this. So in essence, uh
what I think Bugamman's kind of offering
us is a way of thinking about scripture,
the Old Testament specifically, but it
kind of crosses over into the New
Testament as well as a kind of tussle in
ways, especially certain stories and and
um books of the Bible as a kind of
tussle between we might call the the
kind of symbol or the archetype of the
king and the symbol or the archetype of
like the prophet.
So, and if you kind of read the Bible,
you know, like both of these figures pop
up, right? There are kings, there are
prophets, and of course, you could read
that kind of there's a level of just the
literal level, like there are literally
people, and they were those roles. But
there's also a kind of symbolic thing
going on there, which is what Bugamman's
kind of hinting at here. Now, as good
Americans, I think we're probably
tempted just kind of intuitively to be
like prophet good, king bad. you know,
this is kind of just our our instinct.
Um, what I want to name though is not
quite that simple, right? It's not for
the king just simply represents um kind
of what is
uh and even the the kind of well you
could think of it like culture um
governmental systems
you know just kind of the the way things
are the system as it as it currently is
that we kind of inhabit right so the
king kind of represents the
establishment so to speak and uh and
those things right aren't as we've
talked about in previous weeks like this
that's that's not like bad you know what
I like culture evil. Well, well, the
truth is it's kind of a mixed bag, you
know, and and of course the sliding
scale. There are some cultures we look
back on, we're like, oh gosh, you know,
like that was a real or that was really
dark time in our culture, you know,
something like that. So, there's kind of
that, but it's not as simple as just,
you know, if it's a culture, it's bad or
if it's kingly, it's it's wrong, right?
Um, but there is plenty of evil, you
know, mixed in and such. So, and this is
kind of the danger that Bugamman's kind
of hinting at, right? The danger is that
the system so to speak. The the king uh
just over time becomes corrupt. Uh it
gets kind of totalitarian. It gets like
predatory. Um gets a taste of power.
Wants more and more and more. Gets a
taste of control. Wants more and more
and more. You know, wants to control
everything and everyone. And you see
that in the Old Testament um in these
kind of like empires you know it's this
revolving door of empires Assyria and
Babylon and uh Persia and uh eventually
as you come to the New Testament you
know Rome and so in essence these are
kind of kingly empire you know systems
that they hold everyone else accountable
but are themselves accountable to no
one. Does that make sense? They start to
kind of even prop themselves up as like
God,
right? The voice, the law, the the way,
you know, it's like and and you can't
question them. So, and what what um and
what happens is we get born as little
babies into those worlds,
into those cultures,
into those traditions, right? just and
it and it works upon our imaginations. I
mean, before you know it, the way things
are
is just the way things are for as long
as anyone can remember
and it gets established,
right? And now the good is that means
whatever is good in a culture, it gets
preserved. It gets passed on. That's
wonderful. Can you see the danger
though? The danger is that the
injustices, the blind spots, the moral
failings of that culture and that system
get more and more established with every
passing year.
Uh it's a bit like kind of imagine like
a a rut in a road or a path. Anyone into
mountain biking? It's kind of strange to
be into mountain biking in Texas. Um but
it's possible. it can be done, you know.
Basically, they they tend to, at least
around here, they build mountain bike
trails into creek beds, you [snorts]
know, SO IT'S LIKE, WHOA, YOU KNOW, IT'S
KIND OF, OH, I'M GOING into the into the
creek, you know. Um, I personally am not
a fan of mountain biking. Uh, it's too
exciting for me. [laughter] I mean,
truthfully, I'm like, I don't need more
anxiety in my life. This is not my jam.
Um I know people love this, but um one
thing I noticed when I did I've been
mountain biking and such and it's
interesting that in these certain areas
you'll get these like all of a sudden
the just narrow thin but like deep ruts
and it's a disaster. Avoid the ruts. Do
do not get in the rut. I mean it's weird
because it just it takes control of your
bike. You know what I mean? Like you're
you get into that rut and it's all a
sudden just taking you and I mean it'll
toss you crazy ways. You got to avoid
the rut. Now the thing is though, how do
these ruts form? Like is it just
erosion? Well, what happens is it rains,
right? Gets soft and this path people do
this over and over and over and right.
So then it forms then that Texas sun
comes out, bakes it into rock and now
that it's just there and it's
established, right? So it is with
culture. We just do things a certain way
and at first it's malleable and there's
kind of debate, you know, but over time
it it it just kind of um it becomes so
normal we can't even imagine things
could be any different.
And again, some of that's good. Plenty
of it is not so good. But regardless, we
can't even see it anymore. We have no
alternative imagination.
So into this kind of picture steps the
prophet
and the role of the prophet is to be an
outsider.
An outsider that we did not even know we
needed. That the prophet is the
disestablishment
to the establishment. Right? They are
the the counterculture to the dominant
culture. uh many would call them
troublemakers
and what's interesting is they almost
always come from the fringes
right ne rarely from the center of the
culture. Uh this is why verse one of our
passage passage says in those days John
the Baptist came preaching in the where
the wilderness of Judea. Notice John was
not to be found in the city. Heck, not
even in like a small town. No, no. In
the wilderness. Why the wilderness? The
wilderness is a symbol of that which has
not yet been tamed by human culture,
right? By by human systems of control,
by a stifled kind of set imagination.
It is that which lies outside the
boundaries of civilization,
outside the norm, the way things are.
And this is why over and over and over
again in the Bible, the word of God
comes to the people of God from the
wilderness.
Or vice versa. Sometimes the people of
God are led out to the wilderness to
receive the word there. Right? Sometimes
it comes from the wilderness, sometimes
they go out. And actually in the case of
John the Baptist, he's there in the
wilderness and the people are in fact
coming to him. And
this in essence is like the prophetic
kind of call or vocation. We might sum
it up by saying prophets are those whose
imaginations
have not been co-opted by the currently
fashionable ways of thinking and being.
Right? the established the normal
ways. So, okay. So, what are like the
implications of this, you know, for our
actual lives? I know that can be kind of
a lot of like theory and Bible and such,
but like what does this actually mean?
So, I'll give you like three
implications. There of course could be
many others, but these are three that at
least came to my mind. Uh first, a
Christianity
that is so cozy with a given culture
that it utterly loses its prophetic
voice is in fact a compromised
Christianity.
You see, it wasn't only John the Baptist
or like certain people, you know, from
the Old Testament or something, certain
prophets um who who kind of entered into
this vocation were prophets. like Christ
himself as the book of Hebrews points
out arrives as a prophet like yes he was
more than a prophet u but he was not
less right there's a I mean there's a
reason Christ stayed largely if you
recall his life outside of Jerusalem
right always kind of in Galilee and out
kind of on the fringes and the people
came out to him and what happened the
minute he started to enter in enter
Jerusalem
How did that go?
Badly, right? This is I mean we'll get
to that in the kind of right now we're
coming into Advent and Christmas and
that's Lint and Easter, right? That's
but but that's where the story goes.
Like in essence, he says outside
Jerusalem. And I I think there's also
there's a reason he tended to critique
the religious and political leaders of
his day while simultaneously befriending
tax collectors and sinners, right? Kind
of outsiders and people of low social
standing as the the gospel kind of put
it. And
so, okay, so how does this kind of apply
to us in our own life? Well, I'll say
like right now in our kind of cultural
moment, um, this is why I have
and why I will continue just to kind of
name and keep front and center for us
that what what I'm kind of discerning in
the Christian nationalist movement. Um,
I think is largely uh not a move of the
Holy Spirit. I think of course God can
always do things in the midst of, you
know, I mean, it would never write
something off like there's nothing good
happen. Well, not nothing, but I just
say largely uh I I think what I what I
well why um because what I perceive
there is is largely folks kind of either
unwilling or unable to have a kind of
critical distance necessary to offer a
very needed and helpful and hopefully a
loving critique of the nation state.
Right? In other words, a Christianity
that seems to be more passionately in
love with America
than the gospels and the person and
teachings of Jesus Christ. It becomes a
compromised Christianity. Why? It's too
it's too cozy with the king, so to
speak,
right? And so what what happens? It
banishes the prophets and the prophetic
voices of those on the margins. And if
you just kind of know some of your
church history, this of course is not
some, you know, new phenomena. Like this
is a recurring problem. And it just
never goes well. Christianity at its
best when it's really reflecting Christ
tends to be a bit more on the margins.
tends to be a bit it's a bit more
prophetic than it is kingly. Does that
make sense? Uh and so I think this is
this is why we have to be really careful
of uh kind of the the movements that we
might be kind of tapping into or
deriving like energy and passion from.
Uh so that's the kind of first
implication. Second implication, uh some
people cannot help but function in a
prophetic way. They're often artists,
outsiders, and countercultural weirdos,
quote unquote, who see differently
and thus help to keep alive the ministry
of imagination.
This again is something Bugamin really
helped me to understand and it really
changed like how I read the Bible and
how I read the Old Testament prophets.
uh because he pointed out I was like I
don't know how I never noticed this but
he said prophets are artists
and if you read their books they are
poetic they are visionary it's like it's
never just kind of mundane language
it is I mean it's it's just incredibly
artistic
and uh imaginative and countercultural
right in essence Um,
it's it's almost like right when God's
people are in this place of saying,
"We're fantastic.
We're the best. We're the brightest. God
loves us and only us." You know, uh,
just know a prophet's about to come
along and offer just a wallup. Like,
it's just it's it's going to happen,
right? like the the prophet's just
constantly like get off your high horse,
right? I mean, you'll recall from our
passage, the words of John to the
religious leaders
who, by the way, were coming out to hear
him. Now, maybe they had kind of
ulterior motives here. You know what I
mean? Like, I I don't know. Or maybe
they were genuinely. I'm not sure. But
nonetheless, when he saw these leaders
coming like I mean the normal protocol I
got say we had like all of the Saxy city
council here tonight like just in
theory, right? It would be sort of
protocol. Oh, we like to thank you know
what I mean? Like that's what you do.
What did John the Baptist do? He was he
like, "Oh, good. The the movement's
growing. We're getting a little cache
here. This is really working." No. What
did he do? I mean, listen to this. when
he saw the Pharisees and Sadducees
coming where he was baptized. He said to
them, "You brood of vipers." And that's
not something we normally say, um, I'm
assuming it's not good. At least from
what I know, vipers, not good. I'm
guessing ancient near east, this was not
a, you know, compliment, right? Who
warned you to flee from the coming
wrath? This is the religious leaders.
They're the ones doing the warning. You
know what I mean? But he's he's warning
them. It's like, yeah, a pastor
gathering or something. And like he
starts warning all the pastors, you
know, like who who want you to flee from
the rat? Like it's just he's like
flipping things upside down, right?
Produce fruit and keeping with
repentance. Don't think you can say to
yourself kind of this pedigree thing.
Oh, we have you should know our
ancestors. How spiritual, how wonderful.
We have Abraham as our father. No one
else has Abraham as their father. You
know, it's this kind of lineage thing.
And he just trashes it. Like, oh, I God
God can raise up children of Abraham
from the stones, you know, just I mean,
just what is he doing? is it's brutal.
Brutal.
I mean, this is this is the prophetic
vibe. This is the prophetic way. This is
this is the tradition. Um, now from
this, you may think like, am I also God,
prophets, are like jerks, you know,
prophets are always mean. Um, I wouldn't
say that though. If you've read them,
you know, Isaiah and such, Jeremiah, um,
it's more like they just zigg when
everyone else is zagging. Isn't that
artists, too? You know what I mean? It's
like the minute everything becomes like
this is the way, this is the way we do
it. This is how we do it. This is how we
write songs. This is how we make movies.
This is, you know, I mean, this is the
acceptable culture. Like, this is the
way you should do a podcast. This is how
you do like just this is the way. And
the artist is like, oh god, no. You know
what I mean? just immediately like,
uh-uh, we got to because this because we
just get too immune to this. You know
what I mean? It's just this what I'm
used to. This is the way. This is the uh
and so for example, there's actually um
moments in scripture where God's people
are not in the place of we're the best,
we're the greatest, we're actually the
opposite. They're like, we're the worst.
We're the worst. God's abandoned us. God
hates us. And then what does the prophet
say? The Lord loves you with an
everlasting love.
That's like from the Bible, right?
That's the same prophets. Like, what the
But can you see what they're what
they're doing, right? They zigg when
others zag.
They don't always tell us what we want
to hear. They're always telling us what
we need to hear.
Um I I think in many ways, this is
something my own kind of evangelical
upbringing, we just largely seemed um
not to understand. I think we were
probably a little a little well, we were
a little too kingly, a little too just
kind of in a certain vein and um we
couldn't really hear from, you know,
weird people, different people,
controversial people. It's like we ran
from anything different like it was of
Satan automatically, you know, not
realizing that it was often artists and
poets and musicians and so-called
weirdos and outsiders who really were
perceiving and giving voice to truths
that we just could not stand to hear but
desperately needed.
I'll give you a few examples of this.
Um, one I think modern-day prophet is
Tiknad Han. Uh, God rest his soul. He
just passed away. He was a prophetic
voice in the west for the last really
like since the 60s, so like 60 years.
Um, his teachings on mindfulness,
peacemaking, openhearted living. Um, he
was a major critic of the Vietnam War.
um he was just incredibly
countercultural and I think in many ways
um
kind of an antidote
to
uh what kind of ails a lot of western
culture but as a Vietnamese and Buddhist
um I think many Christians just didn't
ever pick pick it up didn't really tune
in you know just couldn't couldn't hear
it couldn't receive it couldn't possibly
even comprehend that God might be
speaking a word through someone um like
this. Another example, Dorothy Day.
Dorothy Day was uh part of the Catholic
worker movement and uh really a true
pro. She was like kind of early to mid
20th century and um you know in time
like during the great depression and
such started all sorts of it's called
the houses of hospitality movement. this
kind of um grassroots persontoperson
um very extremely hyper local. She
believed in hyper hyper hyper local
ministry just onetoone and changing kind
of hearts and minds and loving people
and connecting with them in that very
face toface way um as opposed to just
sending millions of dollars kind of
through an organization abstractly. You
know, she really wanted to be face to
face and connect with people and um but
she but she was a prophet. You read some
of her writings like she's brutal. She's
tough. Tough on honestly people like me,
pastors, priests, the religious clergy
and hierarchy and such. Tough as nails.
Um, and yet also she was deeply
faithful. I mean, she was at mass every
day. Every day saying her prayers and
engaging and you know it was a kind of a
beautiful, beautiful um life, but she
really did work tirelessly on behalf of
the poor and oppressed um giving that
prophetic voice. Another modern day
prophet, David Foster Wallace. I think
he's another kind of more secular modern
day prophet, but the way he kind of saw
how visual kind of media um it's like he
kind of foresaw it, I don't know, 20
years out and saw how television and the
internet and social media and such would
come to kind of dominate and begin to
erode our capacity to um be quiet. I
mean, he was just way ahead of his time
um in that way. Uh, finally, I also
think many in the LGBTQ community are a
prophetic voice to Christianity. I think
especially of um LGBTQ artists and such,
I think they're pointing out our blind
spots. They're naming places um where
we've uh as a church, we've just kind of
been largely unattuned
to what the Holy Spirit is actually up
to.
And so of course, you know, a lot of
these like I love I like these prophets,
you know, so it would be maybe easy for,
you know, me to pat myself on the back
and be like, well, I listen to the
prophets, you know what I mean? I'm I'm
open. I'm openhearted, you know, not
like those other people. Um, so let me
name that there's a danger for us, too.
And this is the third implication. I'll
close with this. Be careful of fancing
yourself as so prophetic that you become
immune to the prophetic voice.
And here's a hard truth. Um I think it's
true for me. I think it's true for all
of us. I am myself today
um inescapably blinded and co-opted by
my own culture by its norms and values
and ways of being
and really in fact to say you know a
ticknahan or LGBTQ people or prophetic
voices you know it doesn't mean we can
just sort of naively kind of um find a
firm place to stand there be like as
long as we listen to them well then
we're great there's no one can critique
there's no critique that can come
against me you know
H no, it's it's not that's not how life
works, right? Um
there's there's really no easy place to
stand really. I think all we can do is
kind of stand where we stand, speak what
we see as honestly as we see it. Uh and
at the same time,
uh have the humility to say, "Oh Lord,
and reveal to me my blind spots. Help me
see. um give me the prophetic words that
I need. So, here's the practice I want
to invite you into this Advent. We kind
of have two options. This is like a
choose your own adventure advent. So, a
if you're more inclined to kind of stay
silent about things,
then I want to encourage you to um speak
up, speak out, like start to practice
kind of some of that prophetic um
imagination and voice. So that might
look like um you know having a difficult
conversation with someone that you've
been kind of avoiding or maybe it's
writing you know that blog post or
linking that article that you've you
know held off on. Um or if you're an
artist maybe it's actually working on
that piece you've been putting off. Um
well you know whatever kind of prophetic
thing you might have been avoiding I
encourage you like engage that. Do it.
Put it out there. um kind of step into
that in this Advent season. Um or
second, if you're quite inclined to
speak out about things, you're like, I
have no problem doing that. Um okay,
well then maybe intentionally make this
Advent a season of listening
by seeking out voices very different
from your own views. Um a good example
of this I heard about, it's not related
to Advent, it was specifically related
to Lent. Um but it was a writer,
Christian writer named Peter Rollins and
he had um he called it for Christian
churches called atheism for lent and it
was a time where Christians would
intentionally read um atheist critiques
of religion and Christianity
to as a as a listening practice to
discern
what here um might there be a truth I
need to hear. Right? In essence, um it's
often outsiders who have a certain angle
and insight into our own traditions that
we as insiders, we just can't see it.
We're too close to it.
And that's that's one example of uh of
kind of intentionally engaging
voices
um that are very different than yours um
and but kind of opening yourself up to
it, you know, or maybe if you're here
tonight, you're kind of more in that
agnostic place or something. Well, then
maybe it's the reverse and you're like,
I'm going to intentionally really engage
that Christian material or something,
you know, or something. Um and you could
do this, you know, along political
lines. You could do I mean, how however
you'd like. But um I really encourage
you to um basically seek out the
opposite kind of opening yourself to the
prophetic critique from unexpected
places. And this of course is not easy.
Um but oh, it's a chance. It's a chance
for the Holy Spirit to um both to kind
of use us, if you go for option A, um
and to surprise us, if you go for option
B, to kind of fire our prophetic
imaginations in fresh ways as we prepare
our hearts to receive the truth of
Christ this Advent. In the name of the
Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit.
Amen.
So as we
uh come to the table tonight, we
remember again uh Christ, the one who
loved us, the one who gave his uh body
and blood for us. And on the night Jesus
was betrayed, at one point he held up a
loaf of wine or a loaf of bread and uh
and he broke it and he said, "Take this
and eat. This is my body broken for you.
And then he held up a cup of wine. He
said, "Take this drink. This is my blood
shed for you. Whenever you eat this
bread, whenever you drink this cup,
remember me." So I encourage you as you
come forward to have that just open up
your heart. You know, have this moment
to uh to connect with the mystery um
that is Christ. Uh the way we'll go
about this is we'll just start here at
the front and we'll just go row by row
working our way back and forming one
line here in the middle. Uh we practice
what's called an open table. So if
you're here tonight, you want to
participate, feel free to do that
regardless of your exact, you know,
theological beliefs, um you're welcome.
If you you want to connect with Christ,
then you're welcome to come forward and
do that. Just know the red is wine, the
white is grape juice. And finally, you
can just partake whenever and however
you'd like. Some folks like to come here
and kneel at the front. Some take right
away. Um but you can just partake
however you would like to. So this is
the table,
not of the church, but of the Lord. And
it's made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more.
So come you who have much faith and you
who have little. You who have been here
often and you who have not been here
long. You who have tried to follow and
you who feel like you failed, come.
Come because it's the Lord Jesus himself
who invites you and it's his will that
those who want to meet him should meet
him here. Come to the table.
>> [music]
>> Lift me up
as Arise.
Strength of God.
Go before. [music]
Lift me up
as I wait.
Eyes of God.
Look upon
my side.
>> [music]
>> You guys feel free to stand and sing a
good thing.
>> There's a way
of God
satisfied [music and singing]
and sustain
[music] as I heal.
of God
lead me on. [music]
Be my God.
[music] Be my God.
Above and below [music and singing] me,
before and behind me, in every
[music and singing] eye that sees me.
Christ be all around me. of love and
belonging [music]
before and behind me. In every
[music and singing] reality sees me,
Christ be all around me.
as a go. [music]
Here's God.
Lot of sins [music]
by my side
as we rest.
Thank you, God. [music]
All
give me peace.
[music] Bring me peace. Peace
above and below.
Before [music]
and behind [singing] me, in every island
that sees me, Christ be [music] all
around me, above [singing] and below me,
before [music] and behind [singing] me,
in every se
all [singing] around me. [music]
Oh
[music]
Christ be all around [singing] me.
Oh
[music]
Christ be all around me.
Your life, your [music] death, your
blood was shed for every [singing]
moment.
Every moment is your life,
[music and singing]
your death, your blood was shed [music]
for every moment.
every [music]
moment. Your life, your death, [singing]
your blood [music]
will shed for every moment.
Every [music] moment is your life, your
death. Your blood [music] will shed for
every moment.
Every [music] morning
[music]
and
everybody
in [music and singing] every eye that
sees me. Christ be all around [singing]
me. Above and belonging [music]
before
me in every eye that sees me. [music]
Christ be all [singing] around me.
Oh
[music]
Christ be all around [music] me.
Oh
[music]
Christ be [music] all around [singing]
me.
Thank you so much for [music] being here
tonight here in the building. And to
those of you online, I hope the [music]
service blessed you um and helped you to
prepare yourself for the week ahead. Um,
if you are new, uh, please make sure to
fill out a card on your way out or you
can scan the [music] QR code that will
be up on the screens and fill out an
online biz [music] card. Don't forget
Hat Creek tonight. Right after we're
done here, we'll head over to Hat Creek
Burger Company and Saxi for some food
and to continue the conversation.
[music]
Um, I would love to send you into your
week with a benediction. If you're
comfortable doing so, please stand to
your feet. Otherwise, you can stay
seated. You can hold your hands out
in a posture of receiving or you can
just open your heart [music] to these
words that I truly believe are true for
each and every one of you.
You are a child of God.
You are a [music] child of God.
This is true on your best day and it's
true on your worst day.
So as you go into [music] your week
ahead with it's yet to be considered
highs and lows and everything in
between, [music]
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved, you are worthy, [music]
and you are accepted just as you are.
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
[music] the desire to extend these same
gifts of grace and unconditional [music]
love to everyone you come in contact
with. Be blessed. We'll see you next
Sunday and we hope to see you at Hat
Creek. Good night.
before and behind [music] me. When every
eye sees me, Christ be all
[music and singing] around me, above and
below me, before and behind
[music and singing] me, in every eye
that sees me. Christ be all around
[music and singing]
me.
Christ be all around me.
Oh.
[music]